you can't get under things can you dude
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are trying something a little
bit different we are trying a horror
game yes we are going to get scared get
that this is layers of fear too
I've really wanted to play this for
quite a while I wanted to stream this
but I don't think I'm capable of doing
so without swearing so this is my way of
getting through that and testing it but
hey we're in this together right let's
do this now a mirror we have a mirror
it's a good start it's a good start I
like the door physics this is what I do
at home 100 - leave me five minutes love
okay what we doing in here
oh I'm not scared you're scared I'm
feeling good so fun of nothing me okay
something has got my attention not going
that room okay come on come on come on
stay jovial mr. Noyes ease is the
flooded sounds that do you there's a
mask mask to wear I think it's all an
act is it an act
oops sorry wasn't me this isn't scary we
got this guy's
nice mask okay what the hell is this
what the hell is this I'm not scared
you're scared it's a globe around the
world
oh come on shadow the Riverdance how did
you do today how did I know what do you
know what he do that this is how we play
was that racially insensitive my
apologies to all my Irish friends top of
the morning okay okay it's okay it's
okay brother
when I wake up mr. Dee Jeff harder you
gotta get out of this godforsaken prison
before you RuPt okay balls
what is he doing to understand
something's gonna jump out and get me
you all right brother
give me a drink just everyone stay still
we're all if your heads falling off yeah
I've been there me so there's you on
fire okay
oh it's quite a turnout I don't know if
I like quieter or not I just don't like
video games okay this is follow them
random barrows
[Music]
the guy that was best offer that's fine
that's fine okay brother
[Music]
the music is a sound that does it all
the time oh hey brother what we doing me
and you it's watching the sunset
together like two star-crossed lovers oh
look you can ring
[Music]
can we go back please
[Music]
it's the scooter and the carpet from the
shinning the shining us the shinning
Simpsons reference hope somebody got
that mmm back to the cinema what you're
pointing that broke Oh Oh tough to break
OH
the kids like kids sounding music it
just rips you up inside
okay-y room this is music
no no what does that mean just gonna
come out the TV it's gonna come out the
TV
we weren't away
what would you do we are gonna go and
disco party with this guy that's okay
you manned up there with it really well
we didn't get scared we manned up we're
awesome video games you can't scare us
video games try your hardest Oh give me
all Billy big balls and then that
happens the music's building towards
something so rap jokes he didn't get me
- the [ __ ] was that who the [ __ ] was
that and the music game but if that oh
[Music]
cool
oh why am i self ready do this please
look kid come in - please don't kill me
please look we're not that we're not
that we're okay
[Music]
the music's definitely building towards
something oh my heart my heart
oh you stayed that night
is he chasing are we okay do we run or
do we do and don't think we need to run
but I'm still running on the same place
the door it's okay bro we're away from
him nothing to worry about
this bottle do hurry we have to see
can't we take the hollow to take the
hammer and we'll Club him in the head
you should be scared you know what
happens if they find us what happens
they'll send us back yeah you wish money
you wish bro I'm sweating my should I be
shooting these doors you can't get under
things can you dude shines without
without without with that it still
behind you still beyond yourself calm
down calm down calm down it's all right
mommy
just follow the lights
we don't know we don't know we've done
you've got it love are we done are we
done are we done the hunt brandings lung
oh my beloved gosh I love this this is
awesome it's the music in it mate
it's the frickin music messes you up
inside character oh that's a nice
picture this the camera you used yeah
could we take this again there's
something wrong with the picture III
think you missed Oh must have moved no
no no he's gone few open says me Oh
we're doing bro you keep your distance
I'll keep mine yeah whatever I'm going
chase me darling and oh [ __ ] that's what
you're supposed to do
[Music]
are you having fun I'm not you you don't
know if this meet you keep walking down
no ice oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
right this time and expected that I
expected it shut the door and lock it
you can't get any air you proceeded
trike bro come at me bro holy dummy is
the door locked
has he given up
I hope he's given up I think we're okay
I think we're all right Oh
layers of fear please don't be outside
please don't be outside please don't be
outside yeah [ __ ] yeah this is the oh is
it so hard to commentate whilst you
sketch that bloody noise it's oh there's
a guy in the work oh oh oh
there's a boy there's a boy what would
Jesus do make it to the lift and we off
fine brother we are fine in the lift you
stay up there mate cuz I'm sick of these
bloody money kins holy hell fire you
stay there lads and I'll stay here
everyone is happy way down anyway gents
it's been a pleasure and of course
they've gone wow where the hello what
are we going we're going to hell
all these he you can dance if you want
to you can leave your friends behind cuz
if you find I love this game layers do
this alright it's alien isolation all of
a sudden Oh God Oh balls
what do you want me to do
I've got to choose thirdly AAA
I think I have to hold his hand
[Music]
[Music]
the humane run
yep she means we're not looking at
things we are just running and staying
calm because that's what we do when I'm
scared of anything is really bloody
close he's really bloody close open says
me and yeah get it get it get it get it
is we got this man film stuff like that
floaty floaty meets sec I will get going
again and if sometimes I need to take a
breath or even the freaking shadow do
the hell am I right Bob roughs
a door that is that
does that mean oh yeah
I like that right we have a plug what do
we need an electronic plug for yeah we
are going to murder someone where's that
lucky
electrifying okay this is taking a very
seedy edge I don't feel like the victim
anymore and moreover the murderer
hey Han Solo hey dude we watching
anything good
you shoot out keep moving okay okay I
know now that if I don't run when she
says think there's always something
behind me and there is I've led the
rules now would comply you've got it
love I am I've don't hire about enough
let's just get through this no because
I'm gonna scare myself less Oh
- axe left but I don't think anymore
I'm gonna take a break I'll make this
into a video hopefully around 15 minutes
long that you can watch in fact you're
already watching it so it's probably
pointless saying this now anyway thank
you for watching I'm matter from
Playstation grenades if you enjoyed this
I'd like would be appreciated and if you
want more let me know in the comments or
shall we just never touch a horror game
ever again
it's been fun though although my heart
my heart doesn't know it's been fun see
you next time